and joining me now by phone is Housing
and Urban Development Secretary and also
a member of the White House coronavirus
task force dr. ben Carson good evening
dr. Carson it's good to talk to you
doctor I want to ask you about something
that's been in the news for the last few
days and that is the whole idea of the
Hydra what is a hydro chloric one and
z-pak and I understand that you know
that this is not something that's gotten
FDA approval for individuals who are who
now have the corona virus but is it
available for those who want to be able
to use it until we get to the point
where we get a cure or at least a
vaccine well you know these are
prescription drugs and that they've been
utilized for many many years with hyper
ghor has been used for malaria decade
and but it hasn't been used in this
particular context and I think that's
where you know there have been some
who've tried to gin up a big fight
between the President and dr. Johnson
when there really is no room for fight
there is simple simply that doctors are
saying we don't have the data to prove
over the long term that this is
effective and and totally faith in this
setting and the president is saying you
know by the time we get that data it'll
be too late for a lot of people and we
know that it has been used in lots of
settings safely so let's maybe take a
little more risk because we get a lot
more upside well and that's sort of the
difference between a business person and
a scientist Assizes right everything has
to be 0.8 and with the business person
you know it's you know weighing this
person is that well yeah it's really a
benefit I mean if you go through all the
phases of review I mean the the person
who has the virus could be dead but so
you know given that the administration
and President Trump believes in the
right to try well this is now
something where you know there is a
certain compassionate ability at least
to get this stuff but let's talk about
when you think doctor when do you think
we're gonna get to the peak of this do
you have any idea
well we have an idea based on what's
happened in other countries and you know
it's a reasonable assumption that we
would have the same kind of things
happening here
so you know we're probably looking at
you know months hopefully a couple
versus several but somewhere in that
range and of course things are better
because we're treating this very very
aggressively you know as you've noted in
some places you know there wasn't an
aggressive push back and hence you see
just a florid increase and we have some
places like that in our country you know
like you know New York City in
Washington it wasn't because they didn't
push back but they had a lot of people
coming into those areas from outside of
the country kind of places where the
contact doctor I I want to move on to
your position as the head of HUD and I
want to let my viewers know what the
federal government is doing regarding
the moratorium on foreclosures can you
explain that to to my viewers yeah well
you know what is the most important
thing that most people have financially
it's their home and while they're being
terrified by this and trying to keep
themselves in their families faith the
last thing we want them to be worried
about is whether they're going to lose
their house because the payments have
been lagging and so the president
authorized us to go ahead and place a
60-day moratorium on foreclosures and
evictions that were in progress as well
as that may occur over the next 60 days
and will there be okay and I only have a
few seconds left
but if people have trouble paying their
mortgage where there is no foreclosure
what is the federal government offering
well we've asked for forbearance for the
services which means you know we want
the blunt them to look at the whole
cascade of options that they have before
they would even think about eviction or
foreclosure okay and I guess it's up to
Congress to actually pass a law to force
the the forbearance correct well when it
when it comes to the PHAs the public
housing authorities and people on
section eight that for us to be able to
restrict them from doing evictions would
require Congress to act and we've asked
them to do that quite frankly I don't
think you're going to have a lot of
problems with that because they're not
really interested in throwing people out
this situation good dr. ben Carson thank
you so much for being with us and I
appreciate all that you're doing